hello there reject nation
no i'm not happy about it either
i'm not
you guys know what i'm talking about
all that spider-man lotus controversy
that's been going around on twitter can
you guys believe that crap oh my god
no no no i um i use the wrong clip and
then once you do one part you gotta
match it all
everyone's been commenting on it since i
saw my face it's been the news of the
century century yeah all over twitter
it's going to look weird when you see
some pre-recorded videos go up in a full
beard statement on it on twitter you can
just throw it at will on the notes app i
was like craig made a notes app had a
serious contemplation of will rogaine we
go grow
anyway guys we're gonna watch the final
episode of obi-wan today and we are
miked up properly this allows us to hear
each other while we're reacting to this
show guys thank you so much for joining
us on this journey please leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated and your
thoughts down below what you thought
about this episode i want to thank ace
for joining us on this six week journey
it's been a pleasure having squad leader
ace with us go follow his youtube
channel as well one day he'll invite me
on also subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next video is up that will generate
interest for you lastly no no second and
lastly uh full length watch along where
you sync up with the time code with ob1
using your own copy available at our
patreon page for super sexy rejects
cover plenty of shows over there as well
with reaction highlights for several
shows offered exclusively the same tier
i think i said that right real lastly
thank you to them preparable to help us
edit these down we gotta do miss marvel
after this but we want to enjoy obi-wan
first
you guys ready
i'm ready so red the force let's do it
might do it my face is ugly
wait your turn
you can have what's left when i'm done
good luck yo i'm looking for a farmer
oh crap
oh [ __ ] this is our first space battle
in the show yeah it's a star war
man she got there quick i know faster
than them
move all power to the rear shields we'll
head for testing
get you out from there
[Music]
they're reacting to being shot at very
calm
we're not going to make it to tessenabi
motivator's shot
power couplings are bad how much time do
you need
more than we have
is there a ballpark though
[Music]
i'm scared
and she keeps their minds off of it it's
part of her redemption arc we need a new
belt for the speeder certain somebody
broke the last one
your uncle's a patron man i am not that
patient
no wait you can't just leave me here i'm
the one that vader wants if i go he will
follow i'm not letting you leia please
wait you know this plan makes sense no
we need you it'll buy you the time you
need you must get these people out of
here you are all the future you are the
future
leia i find you need to be given space
just you must promise me that you get
her home hodger as soon as i'm in the
clear you have my word
although i know the word of a liar
enough fake dad i may not mean much to
you it's good enough for me the word of
camille
thanks speedo nunjoni
i'm not leaving my home at least here we
have a chance if we stay we need help
i'm not putting anyone else in danger on
[Music]
where enough we both knew the stay might
come
cool say what
she'll come when the suns go down
best we got position now
peru is stronger than i recall i have
something for you
broken found it before we got out
she would have wanted you to have it
ah origins
it's empty
well i wasn't gonna give you a blaster
layer you're 10 years old
it's perfectly old enough
[Music]
i have to face him master
whether he dies or i do
this ends today
are you ready come on
or loved if that was his entrance hobie
you want to do it
it's about you and him
people follow you
don't stop
just get started spin off yeah
buddy we're attracting an escape crap
there's one life form aboard we cannot
prioritize one lone
jedi he is not just any jedi
he is my jedi
follow kenobi
jeez
[Music]
damn i'm gonna wrap all this up in the
next like 20 minutes
there's so much going on
[Laughter]
now luke
i need you to listen to me
the tuscans are on the hunt again
they're reading farms along the waist so
stay in here that's a good cover
prepare my ship
i will face him alone oh [ __ ]
keep the engine running
[Music]
do you know what planet that is
no what good are you is ace get out of
here
[Music]
just based on the shape
some people can't man some people
i mean it looks like you do
they're just trying to that helps
from rogue one
she's here
what is her plan kill luke kill them all
kill him
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh no
it looks like it's coming so fast god
these shots
have you come to destroy me obi-wan
i will do what i must
oh damns i am oh
he did it
then you will die
yes
nice
[Music]
it's much more offensive yeah
he's cooking right now
[Music]
dang
[Music]
oh
hahahahaha yeah
oh
those side flips are dope
oh
[Music]
your strength has returned
but the weakness
still
remains
awesome
sneaky
no vader has a higher ground oh no
oh if he says that
don't say it say it
okay
dang
oh that's mean
did you truly think that you could
defeat me
you have failed
master
come on man it's time to go super saiyan
yeah get that big blonde do
ouch you really love the boy
thank you
he is
[Music]
[Music]
peru
get up spider-man
if you're nothing without the saber you
don't deserve to wield one
oh that's dope though he's been holding
it the whole time
come on qui-gon show up a little burst
of green maybe
[Music]
purpose
dang vader wait come back here
[Music]
tank dude
oh [ __ ]
this is a really great fight
let's go rocks
he's like oh
oh my god
that's why you'll always be a paddle one
bro so aggressive he's in his bag bro
he's cooking
killer luke
murder cold blood really mess with the
cannon
[Music]
oh [ __ ] let's go oh my gosh oh my god
those freaking rock throws man
take that ridiculous
obi-wan really said stay down bro come
on
[Music]
god
oh
[ __ ]
oh there he is let's see his face gonna
see him
[Music]
oh
that's a hell of a shot hot boxing in
there
[Music]
anakin
anakin's gone oh man
i'm sorry
for all of it
i am not your failure obi-wan
whoa
you
didn't kill
anakin
skywalker
[Music]
goodbye
party on darth he's accepted anakin is
truly gone it's like the uh
moment in rebels with ahsoka
[Music]
luke
oh my god he's going to run a ship right
into her
[Music]
damn
ah you can't do it dude
now reba make a choice don't talk like
one of them because you're not
even if you'd like to be
[Music]
two oh damn yeah
[Music]
huh
he's gone
i'll look in the dune see we'll search
till we find him
she's gonna be like i take it back hey
i'm really sorry for the inconvenience
in the middle of your night
sorry for almost trying to kill
when he wakes up to say it was a womp
rat chasing him
just a weird looking tuscan
you got lost looking for power
converters
have i become him
no
you've chosen not to
oh robes are tracking every system
within range
you seem agitated my friend i serve only
you
my master
let the past died
so he had a character or two
gods epic you know i thought luke's
first time seeing a lightsaber was when
obi showed it to him in episode four
not anymore
did he see it though i'm gonna watch
this whole episode back because he was
running away i don't know if he saw it i
just need to know if i should [ __ ]
about it or not fans will debate this
for the next decade i think he saw it
[Music]
oh my god just had the same outfit for
years now
man once you find your look you know
let's go young lady we don't want to
keep you
why are you dressed like a gangster
rapper
i love it
[Music]
good on yaha
so who is it today more cousins
not exactly
hey
my man
[Music]
he's like i don't care about you
thank you of course
we can never repay you
maybe with money i am a babysitter now
so what do you do now
what do you think i should do
i think you should sleep
i think you're right
[Music]
hug her man
you are wise
discerning
these are qualities that came from your
mother but you're also
passionate and these are gifts from your
father and i wish i could tell you more
you don't have to
that's sweet
goodbye
goodbye princess
may the force be with you
hmm it's nice we really gotta discern
what makes her like her parents we spend
so much time on like luke and you know
he's similar and let's really get the
focus on that
i thought you were gonna keep your
distance
and i will
take good care of him
oh well
leave the toy leave the toy
you want to meet him
what
[Music]
i am santa claus
merry christmas
[Music]
hello there yes
dude
i had a failure
that was awesome
he's like man that's a strange old
hermit
guy just said hello and he left who says
maybe the toy is weird
[Music]
he's in a mirage hut
yeah there he is oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh shoot
my dude master qui-gon
ah oh my god i was always here everyone
we just
we're not ready to see you
come on
you've got a ways to go
what oh no way
leia she was taken
you have a very particular set of skills
skills i taught you
oh my god
cool
bars man a buddy show with qui-gon and
obi-wan dude season two
obi-wan and the ghost watch how tensions
rise as they room together
could you not just walk through the
walls like this
i told you to respect my privacy
master quiet guy you can't just stop in
to teach me whenever you want all right
boundaries dude
oh man is there a post credit
there's three post credits three post
credit scenes and they're all just
trailers for the original trilogy
it's cool
it's a p6 baroo gotta be
a little badass for a change huh that
never happens
i mean she's only in like two scenes i
know but she gotta be like quit being a
[ __ ] you take a gun
yeah here let me get one too we're
fighting back
that's right man even beru got woke it's
crazy i know
dark times were living
people being accepted
equal roles and things ian mcdermott
and
come on they say his name i was looking
away for adjusting something oh that's
cool
but we'll check we'll check it out
we'll shred
miss marvel because you watched obi-wan
you will definitely enjoy
miss marvel
at a pakistani new jersey girl
you weren't upset
i think so
i i think miss marvel can be enjoyed by
anyone i enjoy both i think you can too
but is it the one you watch after the
finale yeah
i bet it is for us to watch it
i think so palette cleanser yeah sure i
think there's a crossover there
all right that was probably why they
debuted them at the same time yes
i love that connective tissue yeah well
i like miss marvel that's a good show
you like it oh it's great let's talk
about that instead of this boring thing
let's speculate on the episode of miss
marvel i mean no it has its own night to
itself so shout out to miss marvel yeah
dude just in time for attend nothing
good in this finale am i right gang dude
this is awful all around
insult
that was a lot of fun epic ass episodes
i loved the uh the choreography of the
fight was cool that was badass right
yeah that was way better than the first
fight because they were both able to let
the force unleashed you know so that was
yeah
it was cool man i love the combination
of like
the grittiness of like
the single shot camera
but also like the cool like you know
rolling around and
you know kind of see uh prequel not
sequel kind of the prequel-ish kind of
choreography style too yeah i get what
we were saying they're kind of a blend
of a little bit of modern day
choreography with the hyperkinetic style
of the previous fight
of the episode three fight
and uh but using a lot more of your
their environment this time around oh
man specifically rocks and boulders
yeah i mean it's so visceral was i the
only one who thought of uh um aang
versus uh fire lord ozai
uh when he in the final battle
uh because cause it's all spires and
he's like
that's right he was basically
earthbending there yeah that's exactly
what it was yeah i was like wait a
minute this is the finale of driving
toward the last airbender there's just
no connective tissue to get us from
there to stealing a bunch of thieves
content thieves
even when obi-wan picked up all the
rocks i was like wait a minute this is
aang isn't it dave felony avatar too
yeah yeah there you go he's just
borrowing stuff from himself
well um i mean i think the jedi
levitating rocks has never looked cooler
than now ever that was cool that was
really cool i mean it was cool the way
they they set it up as far as him like
you know
breaking up and building up his power
and then when he went ham and then the
score was like
yeah
and he's like i got it
all right well we got a lot to sort of
digest but uh yeah let's do a little cut
here and then continue talking about it
all righty-o
all righty by the way guys forgot to
mention this we have uh we had any like
a reviews and uh you know discussions
they go up on
you can find the real rejects on
podcasts i mean where podcasts are found
spotify apple music uh
what am i thinking audible you know
various places yeah
14.99 to listen to us on audible yes per
episode you could either listen to it
free on youtube or pay
14.99 it's those youtube ads though yeah
i might want to pay that 14.99 you might
want to pay that 14.90 now it's worth
every penny no that's not there
to the audience
take us in the car with you actually
there's some subscriptions like if you
follow it or if you rate it you know
that that's a big big help right but
only if you rate it five stars don't try
too hard to sell guys please
please clap don't don't try too hard
all right aces cases yeah the case for
why obi-wan kenobi is so groovy
i mean away y'all saw it
uh do i need to express my opinion y'all
watch the show [ __ ]
you saw what i saw
it won
it was dope man it was a lot of fun i i
love the uh the battle the battle
between obi-wan and vader
was really cool and it was really well
choreographed i like the setting uh i
mentioned before very avatar last
airbender
uh i like the spires
of uh of earth the rock spires planet uh
being used as offensive weapons i
thought that was a really cool concept
as well yeah um and yeah that battle was
i mean it sold pretty much the entire
episode the appearance of qui-gon at the
end was cool uh appearance of papa palps
palpatine
uh palpatine papa palps um was cool too
because we got to see that interaction
between him and vader at the very end to
kind of showcase
where vader is heading in his journey as
far as following
um emperor palpatine
at the start of a new hope the shutting
this [ __ ] down journey
oh no fine i'll let obi-wan go yep so
that way we can
wha what's the line that he has a new
hope
uh
when he confronts obi-wan uh now he
becomes the master yeah yeah yeah i was
about the learner but now i am the
master yeah i guess it doesn't mess with
the canon does it the story everything
messes with the canon because um luke
saw the lightsaber yeah
i'm pretty sure he must have caught
eclipse did he i don't know speculate
you gotta ask him you know he had his
back turned he was running
look did you see that did you see that
did you see that before you bumped your
head buddy did you get in your
peripheral vision or anything like that
um you're gonna debate it for the next
decade i'm telling you i kind of felt
like where it ended is
was this it's kind of the story that
feels like would be the more
[Music]
necessary story to tell i i feel like
i'm like that sounds new and interesting
whatever this path this random journey
he's going on with obi-wan at the end i
mean we still can't see it i mean i'll
try it
yeah i feel like we will because
yeah this the season overall for for me
because i like this finale i i really
quite enjoyed it i was i was waiting to
see where it all ultimately
you know emotionally hit me by the end
um
but
really quick
i mean i feel like you like riva the
most out of all of us
you were bawling your eyes out i was
bawling but she did get me teary
yeah no i mean she i don't know
something about the way the emotionality
of that scene played both in her
performance as well as just that olive
branch as he is sort of standing and and
really inter you know it's like that
scene plays out the way it needs to
because of course owen and brew are
gonna be like
i mean thanks for bringing him back even
though you caused all this just now
thank you you know we're gonna go but uh
yeah that moment of obi-wan
acknowledging her and and that
realization for as odd as her arc
could arguably be over all of the
episodes for what
we got here and for how it ties into her
origin and all that i thought it was
quite a moving scene
yeah
it's a bit of a mix back for me
it's a mixed bag for me like the odd man
out here
um because yeah there's parts of her arc
that are this is kind of questionable uh
yeah of her her
methodology to to going about this whole
it's going against vader thing like she
was she seemed so
committed
to
you know being an inquisitor like so
committed to being an inquisitor and
like i'm going to kill jedi where's
obi-wan fighting up and what
and and then you find out that now her
whole plan is just to get you know close
enough to vader to strike him down and
like
he must have had some point in the last
10 years to be able to
get a little knock on him right i mean
especially considering when you see the
moment she decides to
to go about it and then a bit of the
plot convenience because i thought like
oh vader didn't kill her for a reason
like
like when she just happens to live
uh because you know i'm like obi-wan
died but not obi-wan qui-gon died from a
stab to the gun right she gets to live
most people do isn't that stabbed to the
gut
um
yeah i guess her art was just a little
bit
just raised some questions in the terms
of the approach and there's i like the
the emotional porch i like the
performance of her arc a lot more than i
like the actual story points of her arc
sure that's a good way to put it
yeah i thought moses ingram especially
grew on me as a performer as the season
went along
um
overall that i do feel like i had fun
watching this show i really did and i
really liked episode five a lot i didn't
quite love this show overall by the time
all is said and done
like don't i don't want a lot of people
have very black and white thinking would
you say something like that i liked it i
did i had my issues i wasn't as moved by
it as as i wanted it to be
and i didn't
it didn't quite give me the
didn't quite
justify or necessitate the the the
journey for me
of like why are we doing this when it
feels so plot heavy
like okay
by the time they get to the moment where
obi-wan confronts anakin when his you
know the the mask is all sliced off it's
a great shot
and then he's talking with riva and he's
telling riva and like now you're free we
both i felt like nothing in that moment
because i was like yeah you know i i get
where you you're kind of you have to
tell me what you're writing about
but i already got it you do that it's
pretty clear it's really on the nose
dialogue uh but it didn't it was this
season is built so focused on like
moving plot along and i was like well i
feel like that emotional beat and the
purpose of this journey was that right
was to get obi-wan to the point of
accepting you know the resolve with the
guilt that he's felt this whole time
especially to have a land a line like
anakin lay down
of it wasn't you who killed anakin it
was me who did it you know like having
that resolve was the thing obi-wan has
needed so like okay i get what that's
the whole point of this journey as i
supposed to to check in on obi-wan and
that's why i was saying that the stuff
that feels like kind of new and
refreshing and something that would feel
like a coolness surgeon is the stuff
they were setting up for another season
yeah because the way that they talked
about in interviews made it seem like
yeah we might do a season two who knows
maybe
but then i watched someone you guys seem
like you're literally setting up a
season two uh that you have to go about
so
yeah overall i liked it it was fun this
is mainly an action episode and um i i
did feel lack of
stakes throughout it was cool
but
i didn't really find the emotional pull
as much as i
was sort of hoping um
sort of get because
yeah just kind of lack tension and
intensity and since even like with riva
hunting down
luke i like it always look cool i
thought that all that [ __ ] looked cool
like when she's hunting down luke and i
like seeing owen and beru like look at
you guys actually doing some [ __ ] that's
cool
um but you know you're like man they're
gonna be fine it's [ __ ] luke
skywalker
it's more about i think it was more
about what's going to happen aretha
right i think that was like a big
question in the air in this episode and
if i cared more about her i would yeah
then i'd be like yeah what's going to
happen but but i feel like that's maybe
what they were going for as far as that
that entire scene is like is she gonna
get shot and killed is obi-wan gonna
come in and take her head off is it
gonna be like
you know like it was like
anything it's anyone's guess right like
if they did do that if they did have
like obi-wan show up and be like this
time i'll make sure you're yeah like i
would have been like okay cool i'd buy
that if they had bruce shoot her in the
head i would have been like okay cool i
buy that too like either
way she exited the show
i think was the bigger question as far
as like how are they going to do it so
yeah did you really you yourself like
just on your own
um personal opinion like did you really
like riva a lot to the point where
you're like i really want to really care
about her journey i liked her i don't i
don't know about like care about her
journey but i i think you know i i think
her story worked for
what it was doing for the show and what
she was kind of meaning for
the ob1 character because i think that
was the
point of it i don't know if it was
necessarily to make us feel like
this is another character that we're
going to follow and
now we're going to see her in season two
like i don't think that's the point at
all i think right that's all wrapped up
and done
they're going to move on from that i
think the point was mainly just to
connect
anakin and obi-wan together and she was
kind of the connecting factor uh for
that and i think the point of the show
i mean for me right this is me talking
um i think the point of the show was
not quite to
necessarily
create something
you know special and unique especially
with a character like obi-wan that is so
well known and on a planet that is so
well known which is tatooine or at least
we speculated that he would be on
tatooine but i think it's mainly human
and i and i really do feel like
uh an underrated aspect for
uh shows and movies nowadays
is to bring a character a beloved
character back with a beloved actor who
plays that character and who's known to
be that character i mean we just had
news for
kid harrington returning as jon snow
like when you hear that you don't hear
oh i'm so excited for jon snow you're
not really like oh john you're more like
okay kit it's kid we trust kid
and that's more of what i think that
show was this show was going for as far
as you and because you win is like oh
okay two and mcgregor he's obi-wan
let's see him be obi-wan and i feel like
that's a big
factor for a lot of prequel fans like
myself who wanted to see obi-wan return
mainly to see ewan mcgregor back because
we know
he's so good as obi-wan that's a good
point
no and i think um i would i guess i
would say overall i felt that it
served that to cernix i think it's i
think i i agree because even mcgregor is
so good he's good
the performance of him is so good well i
thought the writing of this show was not
that could have definitely pushed i
don't know about pushing the envelope
but just got a little bit more
intimate well with his journey i think
that the you know what i really think is
a big factor is
for a lot of people i've heard this
sentiment of expecting it to be
something that feels a bit more
meaningful or a bit more sweeping and i
think when you name a show
after a specific character rather than
naming it a title
you kind of create an expectation or an
onus to do something of a character
study and i feel like the amount of
character studying and really truly
intimate moments we spend with obi-wan
are
some of the more effective moments and
more rousing moments of the show but
they're also very few and far between
and it was like
during that early scene with him and
leia when he's reassuring her you know
as he's about to leave her on the ship
and everything and why he has to do this
i i was having that moment of like i
would like to be more moved by this and
i feel like i felt like so much of the
show yeah yeah yeah and it's like across
the board it always looks i love what it
looks like and i love what it sounds
like uh you know the the production
values are top top notch but yeah i feel
like there is kind of this expectation
or
uh you know a sort of responsibility
even to if you're going to bring the
character back with an actor we've all
been wanting to see
you know is something that's a little
less clearly focused on plot because it
was also during this episode when uh
rokin is like wait a minute
you have a death wish you wanna go like
it's not even about us and i'm like
cool
i wish we could have gotten there
ourselves instead of having this fast
track and just have you tell us and then
oh no now we're thinking about that yeah
i felt like there were either
character beats or emotional beats of
scenes that were
too much was kind of glossed over
or just skipped entirely to the point
where like a scene would roken like that
like when did this relationship develop
enough to the point when roki would be
having this kind of
you know straight confrontation with him
about obi-wan's death wish with peter
you know yeah so that was kind of the
the
that was just the quality that that i
was i don't know i mean i i would be
what i would be more curious about is to
see what it would feel like to watch
this in one sitting sure yeah to see
like is this as messy as i think it is
or is it just because we took a week a
break in between
if you binged it yeah a lot of people
have mentioned if this was a movie as
well maybe cut some stuff that you know
was just kind of filler in between and
making more about the emotional journey
like john's saying uh it also could have
worked as a movie as well i feel like
that could possibly be a good point this
could have been like a good two and a
half hour movie yeah well wasn't that
part of what the phase were in now is
they were going to make a bunch of
specific movies and then solo happened
and they were like we can never attempt
that anymore make everything shows
because that's what's working now i i
think it was more
the mandalorian was so successful yeah
um that i feel like they were like oh we
gotta pump up disney plus
uh so let's transfer everything that we
had planned for movies into shows i mean
to be i'm not even joking i think that
was what how how the man lauren
got created was i mean they were going
to do a a boba fett movie and then they
scrapped that with uh i think it was
tranq
uh josh trank
and then they it was james bengal
i think it was before james mango was
josh trank was attached
and then they were going to make a boba
fett movie and then they scratched that
and then john favreau was like okay what
if we try boba fett but don't call it
boba fett and just create a character
that looks like him but he's a
completely new character and then that's
how they created the mandalorian and
they said cool let's do this but let's
do it in a show so they created that for
the show well i think sometimes when you
already when you're dealing with star
wars you know like
like the star wars uni cinematic
universe is different than the marvel
cinematic universe because what you
really adhere to with the star wars
cinematic universe is a timeline
you know and and you have to be kind of
you know like religious
towards
events and and and like what is canon so
you don't mess with the timeline
and and and so you're already working
within a box and then when you're
bringing when you're doing a character
returning one then you're even more in a
box of what you can do with that
character so
like talking about instead of doing boba
fett but doing mandalorian you're still
working in the timeline box but now you
get a little bit more to kind of have
some freedom to kind of do a little bit
more and i think you know some of this
was just feeling a bit kind of a lot of
this was feeling like a little
repetitive to me of like a bunch of
things we've ever it feels a little
episodic
it feels like there's other star wars
stuff that i love it just felt like
repetitive
to me honestly yeah it teetered for me a
lot because you know yeah you do have
this sort of chase that swallows up a
lot of the progress and we gotta get a
lot of places fast um and it ultimately
sort of felt like it
kept
teetering back and forth between
the best way i can put it is this feels
like a chapter in obi-wan's story but it
didn't necessarily feel like the next
pertinent chapter except at times when
it really started to converge with
anakin and darth vader and where all
that is now like the most personal
aspects
and so yeah
like what you're talking about with like
it's ending on a note of like i kind of
want to see that looks really
interesting and fresh and new
it it sort of yeah has that quality of
that could be like a definitive new
adventure whereas this almost feels like
a slice of life that isn't
actually presented like a slice of life
it's presented like a pile of plot
details that have a bunch of things that
you're aware of and a bunch of tensions
that come with this world
uh but yeah ultimately
it's just kind of whizzing by
yeah it was always fun to me yeah
and as long as i'm not bored
you got a recommendation from me
i'm a pretty simple guy like that's like
as long as i'm not bored i'm good you
know well like five and six are those
two these two past episodes are like
this feels like the last two episodes of
the show i was hoping for i just wish
the first four kind of were on
the same level because then all the
action heaviness of these last couple
episodes isn't such a big deal partly
because yeah you've cleared all that
emotional space to get to the punching
and the fighting and the lightsabers
i thought it was cool to see vader lose
though in that regard yeah so cool it
was cool to see how that happened
because
because i think the the last okay
i'm trying to think of the timeline here
you would know better than me
in in episode four he does have
something
before he confronts obi-wan whereas yeah
the last time i felt a disturbance in in
the was it was that what he says last
time i felt the disturbance in the force
was once
yeah was when my one a slight breeze
yeah
that's my father
[Laughter]
no i mean he says when he's when he saw
obi-wan it says um i'll be one we meet
again at last um
when i left you i was both the learner
but now i am the master is what he says
he says no he says master of evil in the
control room with with one of the tarkin
yeah he says something else to him and
so
i don't know i i don't really honestly i
don't really care too much about it he
mentions obi-wan yeah he mentions his
his um last time i felt it was obi-wan
for sure
yeah i guess what it was kind of i think
the main thing that was missing for me
was you know when he starts going like
force on least your full badass the kind
of trajectory of
watching him arc
obi-wan arc back into that full-fledged
forced jedi
just sort of felt a little choppy to me
really i thought it was perfect i
thought it was okay absolutely from
episode three
where he's like working his way when
episode two he was like crappy i was
gonna say a bad word um
he was like really crappy at it and then
episode three slowly building up working
at it sweating a little more but he was
still forcing it and then
four or five building up five he was
like cooking a little more and then
episode six
tapping into that holding up all those
rocks and then just thinking about um
the kids uh luke and leia and then just
really just
going in all the way and showcasing what
i've said since episode one which is
what i've told you guys obi-wan's the
goat like obi wan's like one of the most
powerful jedi ever like ever ever ever
so we saw that and i think that seeing
that it was just worth the price of
admission as a whole
because this is like this is freaking
obi-wan man like this guy cooked vader
cooked him and i was like
this is vader like one of the most
powerful force users ever
and everyone just like kicked his ass
and i loved it because that's kind of
what
i i personally wanted to see as an
obi-wan show was i wanted to see
the obi-wan who who really can can tap
into the forest and and beat pretty much
any single force user um and we saw that
and we saw that slow build-up of him
from three to four to five
slowly work his way up to the force uh
and then all obviously up to way this to
this episode where he fully tapped in
and was back to his prime yeah don't get
me wrong i i love that whole fight yeah
i love that whole that moment especially
yeah even when he is like thinking of
his wives and ghouls
lifting the rocks
um
i guess for me it's like when it when
the show starts off where he's like i
can barely move a pencil you know like i
can't do anything force-wise
i was kind of waiting for that
that scene where he's like
you know really trying to tap into the
force to the best of his abilities and
then he's the true struggle of maybe i
can't get it yeah it's like it seemed
like there were
like there's stuff contextually where
i'm like i kind of like that it's more
emotionally provoked to him like like
like in in the episode that everyone
seems to hate as if it's the worst thing
to ever exist in the history of humanity
the the one we're on the inquisitor ship
that's episode three yeah that's four uh
oh inquisitor [ __ ] my bad yeah yeah um
yeah you're dumb ass
makes the worst case for a star wars
expert just saying no in your face it's
true you want to fight me
wanna say more bad words here uh so
cut the crap guys
crappity crap but no like when he does
stop the
you know the water yeah i guess like
it's all like i think the thing is you
pick
everything i don't disagree with what
you're saying i i don't disagree with
that it's i just kind of would crave a
little bit more you know especially when
you're you know a show about a jedi like
let's see a little bit more of those
scenes that are more
you know slowing down and reflective and
getting to kind of rest a little bit
more in the emotion that i agree that
way we can see a little bit more of that
internal journey because i uh as i'm
talking about is i like how it is
emotional situations that kind of
propels him more to be back in tune with
the force i'm gonna start with episode
two
leia's about to die saves her episode
four
um you know when the water breaks
through the glass and he's just like
[ __ ] full-on and then episode five
he's gotta save people so it's like he
is getting these things so i'm like
that's what i mean contextually i am
getting what you're talking about um
it's it's more just
kind of a little bit of
subjective execution i might have
preferred on some other fronts because
yeah i think like
i think it's
technically there
so much of it is actually yeah so much
of it is there in the beats and the plot
points in the context yeah it's just how
they
uh articulate all that truth true very
true yeah but i feel like
when it comes to something like the
force it is something that's so
already subjective
in a lot of different films right
there's a guideline
that's not how the force works oh
there's a rulebook i have
how to use the force for w
there is a there is a lot of
different ways that people tap into it
it can be a life or death situation it
could be
a situation in full rage where you could
tap into a stronger side of the force
like the force isn't just you know
uh just a training montage or like
that's what we need you know
that's what i was saying i wanted
like i really do feel like it can just
come like like that like boom it just
comes all right back it doesn't
necessarily have to be
um you know just like obi-wan
you know training in the cave like it
could be
in a moment he just realizes like oh
crap this is everything i needed to
come and realize to snap right back into
where i need to be at the moment
yeah and he can just be like
and then the force just yeah comes right
back to him
he doesn't necessarily need to
do this
you know step by step process he can
just just like we've seen in other forms
of of star wars movies and media
uh where the force can come into you and
can't comment in the exact right moment
that you need it to come like so yeah
like
so finn
yeah orphan
for for sensitive thing yeah he's force
sensitive yeah yeah so he's going to
tell
uh ken ray before can you tell her
where he sunk in the sand yep off only
like only she knew
everything would have been different if
she had just only known
crazy yep poor thing sorry i know that's
your favorite star wars
it is no it's not but still number two
uh number two
i like my bathroom
uh but no i i think it worked i i i
that's just you know how i feel but i do
i do feel like it worked but i also feel
like when it comes to star wars media as
a whole
i i don't know man i i think star wars
fans are so critical
and it's just weird
when it comes to and no i'm not
necessarily saying you guys
but i'm saying like
we've seen the mandalorian we've seen
book of boba fett
now we've seen obi-wan we've seen the
sequel trilogy we've seen solo we've
seen rogue one we've seen
the prequels and the original trilogy
there's not a lot in any of those films
that are necessarily doing anything
that's like going against the grain and
going against this you know what i'm
saying there's not like the dude star
wars movie character stuff yeah there's
there's it's always like a a tried and
true formula that's followed
but it's done really well and it's done
in a way that people can appreciate and
it's done with different characters
whether it is a boba fett or a dinjarin
or an obi-wan kenobi i don't think
there's necessarily a disconnect between
any of those three and i feel like if
you're a fan of the mandalorian you can
be a fan of of ob1 and if you're a fan
of the prequels you can be a fan of ob1
and the sequels as well i feel like
there is a crossover between all star
wars media that if you are a star wars
fan that's been following it for a while
you can realize like oh that's
connecting to that that's connecting to
this this is a journey here
it's poetry it rhymes like george look
it says george lucas said um i feel like
it's there and i don't necessarily
understand
when people are like but this isn't
doing what logan did or what other media
that i'm referencing did deborah chow
said this would be like joker yeah
it's never she quite i think she did it
that's not that was this is that was uh
for the jurassic world didn't he say
that for that i said his gigantosaurus
would be a joke i'm pretty sure jeffrey
said like i think you're talking about
trevor
also part of the star wars expensive
jurassic world dominion delivered on the
joker yes did it
didn't deliver
much it did sorry i haven't seen it
i feel like when it comes to star wars
it's there you just have to see it and
obviously if you don't want to see it
that's fine and if you don't want to
enjoy it that's fine but i just feel
like
there's there's never really
you can't compare this to like where's
the joaquin phoenix joker where is the
logan or where is the godfather part two
it's like that's not what this is bro
like this isn't what it was like it's
not supposed to be that so yeah
fair i mean i wasn't really coming from
that oh why are you insulting us we
didn't i'm not insulting um
insulting you
you heard it here i'm just joking
don't come at me
put on blast you know who you are you
know who you are
um all right well what's that where
would you rate the show out of 10 ace
off your heart
top of the heart
man that's tough that's really tough
subconscious go use the force i probably
do i'd probably go on eight nice
nice ace i'm gonna be all pitchfork
media about it and i'm gonna say 6.8
nice
three out of ten
right this is hard oh my god why did i
put the pressure on you um i think it's
definitely take a decimal bro i would
say i'm not going to meet you at six
point i'm i'm i'm naturally just feeling
a 6.5 that's what keeps wanting to come
out of my mouth this is 6.5 i'm feeling
like a 6.5 that that the 6.5 that's
filled in like there's some really good
stuff in there and there's that extra
you know the extra relief is just like
ah
there's certain things i just wish
reached a little further
yeah definitely
remember how they made full use of the
inquisitors dude they're so good
they're they do way more than just
bicker
those would be incredible
that fight that moment didn't remind me
the ahsoka moment and uh yeah yeah and
uh like episode of rebels when
oh no i i think i've forgotten now
because
something about the inquisitor the
inquisitor yeah that's that's the thing
that reminded me of what you're talking
about is people going like man the
inquisitors they look silly like they
just bicker and they don't amount to
much and then i heard various people
saying like well that's pretty much the
inquisitor
yeah and that's an incident
i didn't begrudge them that one bit i
actually found that kind of entertaining
that's kind of what they are and the
animated shows as well
so the middle
yeah i like i it took me a a while to
enjoy rebels if i'm being totally honest
i recommend you guys go back and
re-watch clone wars and rebels great
shows both of them great shows
both of them have
hella silly stuff in it oh yeah yeah
they're silly more takes a while again
who makes everything sound like a serial
commercial i went back and watched the
quinlan quinless voss episode quinlan
boss episode repair yourself when he
would show up here yeah cause i thought
he was gonna show up which he never did
um and holy crap there's like um
what's that guy's name zero the hutt
yeah and zero the hut goes back to
nawahata which is his home planet and he
meets and he's like hanging out with his
mom and his mom is like got this
southern
like twang to her dude
and then size noodles is like cooking up
with zero
and size noodles is like a 1920s like
uh like
girl like who's like a dancer and she's
like
let me tell you zero
back in my planet and it's like this we
and i was like this is
the weirdest thing i've ever seen in my
life
and people are like this is my star wars
and i'm like yo go back and re-watch it
y'all like it makes me happy
it's fun and i love it but it's very
very silly
but i i think the
the final few episodes of clone wars are
some of the best oh it's great he's ever
been yeah yeah yeah but that i mean
that's the new team though that was the
the new um
the re
when they brought it back yeah when they
brought it back in yeah but anyway guys
um i love starburst
no [ __ ] uh but obi-wan guys um
yeah guys uh let me see here
uh yeah he's okay he's dead
all right greg is texting me i'm sorry
check my message he's gonna have to miss
marvel and because he's bouncing from
the [ __ ] show now
um
he always leaves coy's corner is done
koi always bounces at the last minute
you know when he does
i'm gonna give him so much crap in our
intro it's gonna be so funny we're
he's not going to watch this video so
i'm just going to tell you guys in some
inside baseball here i'm just going to
intentionally guilt him just for shits
and giggles
it's just going to make me laugh so much
because he's going to feel so fast
i'm just going to find it so amusing
when he's like i'm sorry
i'm i'm a terrible human being anyway
god damn it
i'll eventually tell him i'm just
[ __ ] with you shouldn't have picked
up the black foot
it's time to go to that after party we
can't watch an episode of television
prep right now shots fired um guys
subscribe
click that bell follow us
and uh we gotta end this with a patron
anissa oliva
anisa
you know in a lot of ways she's like the
ob one of our
patreons you're
so right about that we actually anissa's
been such a loyal follower of ours for
so long that she became an actual friend
of ours and then when she came out here
to la we hung out with her nice and um
we thought she wanted something else and
i was like that's not appropriate this
time when that could lead us to getting
cancelled what would a patreon and i
jesus niece so you're pushing the limit
and she's like whoa greg that's not at
all what i was getting at gotta push the
limit to find it you're being kind of
creepy and i'm like oh [ __ ] and i have
not put any of this in text message i
thought it was telegram so i could
delete it
but uh now she has it all on her phone
of all the all the things i thought she
was insinuating but keep in mind i was i
was down in the dms i was trying to i
was trying to prevent you know some
creepy thing happening that you could
use against us uh that was my intention
and but i i thought you were being um
it's a little forceful on us you were
it's your fault to me so that's how
you're like the obi wan
you're just too forceful you're always
crossing lines you have no chills so
like we're like whatever like luke and
owen and we're like
just leave us alone
with our water farm just let us be in
the desert what do you want we're not
trying to bother anybody
all she wanted was to give you guys a
t-16 skype
toy
turns out there's a lot of ways to
interpret t16 yeah because i was like
what is this position oh no nobody can't
do that no i could never do that with
john that's uncomfortable um
damn what a patriot
you haven't heard anything
yeah stick around bro this guy's been
pledged for so long yeah at this point
and he's no longer a paycheck at this
point they're numb to what we would
normally say so we have to go as
outlandish and depraved as we can but i
know when we actually hung out uh we
went to we went to santa monica pier
tricks are for kids uh you know we just
took her to a lot of games and [ __ ] and
wanted her to obnoxious amount of prices
she just had to carry around
so
uh yeah that was a lot of fun and uh
nothing inappropriate happened that
unfortunately for her anyway thanks and
he's heard it your friends
hit up real rejects in the dms yeah we
don't take you to santa monica
you want to miss out on the ferris wheel
let's do it
[Music]